sie kommen nur mit dem nötigsten
bekleidet über die grenzen klammern sich
in der kälte an die hände ihrer mütter
sind getrennt von ihren vätern und
wissen nicht ob sie sie überhaupt jemals
wiedersehen kinder von putins krieg
traumatisiert ohne verständnis für das
was um sie herum passiert
mehr als eine halbe million ukraine sind
schon geflohen zehntausende von ihnen
nach rumänien empfangen von freiwilligen
helfern mit essen und warmen getränken
unter ihnen lena und ihr vierjähriger
sohn atem
ich kann nichts erzählen ohne sofort zu
weinen
die situation ist sehr schwierig
da sind viele kleine kinder babys und
sogar neugeborene
aus kinderheim aus krankenhäusern
alle sitzen unter trap fuß auf den boden
sie warten immer nur auf den nächsten
knall
alena und atem haben es geschafft über
die grenze nach rumänien raus aus putins
kriegs fälle nur noch frauen kinder und
alte menschen können zurzeit das land
verlassen ihre männer väter und söhne
bleiben zurück um für die ukraine zu
kämpfen
sein vater und ich haben einen zweiten
sohn erst 19 jahre alt und ihre freier
bewegen ihn zu kämpfen
dem most das ist das schwierigste
ich wünschte wir hatten zusammen bleiben
können
atem hat sein zuhause verloren den vater
zurück gelassen und ist auf der flucht
im alter von vier jahren nur seine
mutter ist noch für ihn da
die zwölfjährige anna prieske hat noch
nicht einmal dass sie ist waisenkind
kommt aus der nähe von kiew diese woche
kam sie am grenzübergang sie ritt in
rumänien an mit ihrer adoptivmutter
ihre geliebte katze musste sie
zurücklassen
die letzten tage waren anders als sonst
es gab ständig sirenen und wir
versteckten uns im keller um uns vor
raketen beschossen zu schützen
ich habe mein geliebtes kätzchen dort
gelassen
das haus und die schule verlassen man
kann dort nicht mehr hin
ich habe alle meine bücher meine
wörterbücher dort gelassen dabei wollte
ich ein wörterbuch mitnehmen um zu
wissen was man hier sagt
in rumänien wurde anna mit offenen armen
aufgenommen
sie bekam essen und ein bett mit rund
200 anderen ukrainern schläft sie jetzt
in einem überfüllten hotel in zug java
will sich bald auf den weg nach
deutschland machen
[Musik]
erzähl mir von seinem schal wochen
trägst du ihn ich
trage ihn weil ich ihn am allerliebsten
mag er steht für meine heimat die
ukraine erst schön und warm und ich
werde von allen draußen erkannt
und anna zwei von millionen kindern den
putin die kindheit geraubt hat
die kindheit geraubt die unbeschwertheit
geraubt die unschuld geraubt unser
reporter gerät schröder begleitet einen
deutschen hilfskonvoi der ist jetzt in
polen an der ukrainischen grenze wo
hilfsgüter abgeholt werden und bei ihm
ist die 14 jährige bolivianer mishra so
etwas ist ihre geschichte und diana
frische
ja wir haben hier gestern abend als wir
angekommen sind eine ganze reihe von
schicksalen erleben dürfen eine junge
mutter mit fünf kindern ein kind war
erst wenige wochen alt die hier alleine
mit fünf kindern über die grenze
geflüchtet ist und ihren vater
zurücklassen mussten an die front neben
mir steht jana uhl jana ist 14 jahre alt
und spricht sogar bestimmt durch und wie
geht es dir
danke super bowl ja ich habe da einen
großen mut ich spreche lieber englisch
ist einfacher für dich in englisch
ok also ihre eltern sind da geblieben
ich habe gehört deine mutter ist beim
zoll einen zollbeamtin dein vater muss
kämpfen hier hält kontakt
contact us marines
[Musik]
instagram
ja also wir hatten gestern abend auch
kurz kontakt haben auch mit dem vater
versucht kontakt aufzunehmen wir auch
kämpfen soll an der front der dort
arbeitet die mutter ist zollbeamten dach
auch nicht weg muss weiter arbeiten und
liliana ist hier alleine tante und mit
der cousine
von
aids
maybe not long private eine farce
ok also eine ganz erstaunliche situation
wirklich eine sehr positive ausstrahlung
sehr mutig sie sagt sie geht zur schule
sie hat freunde kennengelernt sie kann
hier mit den jungen leuten ja weiter
lernen und hat weiterhin kontakt mit der
familie aber die ungewissheit ist groß
warte als über
ein traum
[Musik]
wird für mich
heimat ja die heimat wird vermisst
vielen dank royaler sind wirklich
schicksal die wir hier erleben die unter
die haut gehen ich bin wirklich
überrascht und stolz auf diesen mut und
diese diesem jungen alter von vierzehn
sich alleine ist und das ganze hier
allein durch steht es nicht großartig
das hat uns tief bewegt und wir sind die
turnhalle ist eine ehemalige schule hier
eine vorhalle
einen hostnamen lagen aufgebaut worden
ist und all das was wir jetzt hier sehen
an eine hilfsgüterlieferung
scooter die gespendet worden sind die
hergebracht worden sind von privaten
leuten auch viele aus deutschland die
hier wirklich mit privaten pkws große
strecken auf sich genommen haben und
auch mit lkws einer von ihnen ist
andreas lange aus ganderkesee bei
oldenburg kann seit gestern riesen weg
gefahren ist hier ganz kurz was habt ihr
alle zusammengekriegt und ist doch nicht
alles was sie gebracht habe nein wären
aus fünf kartons haben wir 80 tonnen
hilfsmaterial markieren mit genmaterial
werden babynahrung werden warme kleidung
organisierten werden jetzt die nächsten
tage noch viel mehr transporte machen
ihr habt gestern bundes hier auch so ein
bisschen erlebt sagt angekommen die
sachen abgeladen hatten hier
reingekommen erwartet den tränen nah
oder ja wissen engagiert aber hier
arbeiten helden und jesus schicksale das
ist unfassbar und juliana die wir gerade
gehört haben dass das ist respekt pur ja
wir haben ja gestern auch gehört es wird
viel material benötigt weiterhin hier
kommen jeden tag weitere leute an auch
mit der nacht waren gestern bis 82 und
es kamen leute mit koffern hier über die
grenze zu fuß sind die eingecheckt sie
haben hier ein dach über dem kopf das
ist wichtig es gibt hier kein zeltlager
ist eine alte schule die gerade dann
altenheim umgebaut werden sollte das
heißt hier ist eine gewisse logistik
vorhanden und es ist hochprofessionell
und die polnischen helfer hier viele
ehrenamtliche machen einen großartigen
job und wenn ihr wollt ihr können auch
ganz kurz war eben in sein zimmer gehen
wie weit man 250 jahre wohnen es sind
hier feldbetten aufgebaut worden die
zimmer haben alles immer einen gewissen
stellen die büsche
friedrichs etikette zurück
[Musik]
so wir sind einmal ganz kurz den raum
hier ist die familie von juliana tante
rosina und so weiter hier keine betten
aufgebaut
[Musik]
vielen dank oriana das sind also unsere
bilder hier aus dem grenzbereich zur
ukrainischen grenze in polen in einem
aufnahmelager womöglich ganz ganz tolle
arbeit geleistet wird und wo wir im
grunde jetzt hoffnung haben dass hier
wirklich die basis ist die leute
herkommen wo flüchten aufgenommen werden
von hier aus weiter verteilt werden
können danke gerhard schröder bild
reporter dort in dieser turnhalle das
ist die logistik die professionelle
logistik hinter den ganzen schicksalen
patricia juliana dort was muss da in
einem jungen mädchen vorgehen mit 14
jahren dann die entscheidung zu treffen
ich gehe